[Music]
in what the f news what the [ __ ] what
the fart submitted by hos Jose Jose
Canseco that's old school do Jose hos
beat school mother who had sex while
breastfeeding her baby upsets viewers
after she defended her decision on live
TV that's weird
wild bris Wow threesome with your baby
to the public so this girl Natasha she
has a YouTube channel so she's a
youtuber that's so cool I love these
youtubers man they're [ __ ] killing
the game I know but these are the new
YouTube the ones that have no moral
compass they're [ __ ] awesome channel
name i [ __ ] with babies the spiritual
Tasha mamma
oh [ __ ] she's spiritual and like her
videos are about like it's mainly about
her breastfeeding her three kids and
she's also a vegan so she talks about
her vegan lifestyle with her family what
is big enough to do it [ __ ] with the
baby I'm just letting you know premise
of her YouTube quality that she uploaded
a video back in 2015 titled do I have
sex while breastfeeding that was the
title Oh asked that question so she when
she started this who did she wait I feel
like there's times where you could just
wait like do I have sex while taking a
[ __ ] yes
here's the video live in life you can
wait and separate the two do I open up a
can of tuna while I suck dick yes yeah
so in this video she was just talking
about how she had been wanting to talk
about that
object for a while what she's nursing
her baby as she's talking about it was
like pretty much all her videos she just
has baby attached shirt size weights
until the babies drop is the baby of
prom
I don't know but she's just saying so in
that video she was saying that at the
time her three-month-old baby was like
super attached to her it's the point
where like she couldn't put him down
because you made him attention anyway
cuz what if the baby just wants to nurse
in peace and he's like why the [ __ ] does
this [ __ ] gotta turn on the camera of a
ton of [ __ ] trying to feed myself
yeah man she's just nursing the baby
she's talking about when the baby was
three months old the baby was super
attached the baby was sleeping and they
share a bed like the family shares a bed
the whole family and they all [ __ ] so
huh at that time her right now her
ex-husband she said she had sex once
when the baby was still nursing and
sleeping and she was just doing it from
them behind the baby didn't wake up from
the earth way way she was or was she
like this and her legs were up and then
the baby was mine she was probably
sleeping sideways yeah and then maybe
that's how okay like the baby's like
holding on for dear life there is
absolutely no way I could be attracted
to my wife as she is [ __ ] yeah
feeding the time the baby's right there
as the baby do even us right now since
we know the baby's upside down now we're
like in the face there's no way I'm
gonna do that maybe can't even though
that baby's separate and it's it's - no
it's it's like protected Sachs I'm like
I can't [ __ ] do it like we can't like
what is going on yes I guarantee you
like if you're at that stage of crazy
and you're having sex that kids that
grow up being afraid like torpedoes of
[ __ ] no no
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] pool noodles scared raffle no
doubt it's okay I'll drop yes Natasha
was on this live TV show called this
morning at the UK show and stood over
there
well she's your fake interviewed via
satellite the kids seven now and she's
still breastfeeding it so she has a
five-year-old um what is it she has
three kids
I've got girls named Josiah a
two-year-old named Seoul and a
three-month-old named love Todd they're
all [ __ ] stupid ask me I'm just
kidding
can you imagine this kid grows up and
then he's like known as the kid who was
there watching wash your parents [ __ ]
why are you giving the I know
don't she keep stressing that the baby
was sleeping and I like when I was
reading the story I felt stood disaster
I'm like that's what she wants I mean
that's that's perfectly fine I think for
me I don't know if I could do that just
me personally but if she has some people
really good at multitasking and I guess
she's one of them
but I can't be doing [ __ ] like that
she's a guy the guy was thank you horny
while the baby's sucking on her nipple
well that's one but the guy - oh this is
Tasha well what is she what is she
Filipino Cambodian Leyla sharkskin they
don't report what she is but I think
she's Mexican oh oh oh make sense she
looks like she's from a tropical place
yeah and then recently on her Instagram
she's posting a lot in Hawaii so maybe
she moved to Hawaii I was asked texts
all of her selfies have the baby being
breastfed most of them and I'm like most
of her photos to it you could clearly
hold her nipples must be so raw so she
loves showed off her nipples pretty much
energy was it she does they don't use a
Spanish
last name Tasha Sanchez Sanchez Sanchez
she's Mexican well it could also be
Filipino oh really so let me show you
guys a clip of her interview with the UK
show and people saw this it's only it's
a short excerpt so much prettier
the kid on earth got their opportunities
I'm gonna let them walk yeah and so like
your interview is so cringy to watch
because even her answer is they're just
like what are you sure but this is our
American ambassador you don't mean like
people from the UK are watching this and
they go this is this is how Americans
are I mean they're watching us and
they're probably thinking the same thing
here we go okay to breastfeed was having
sex last yeah and what was your reply to
that well I think she's not good at all
about the conversation and getting to
more of like the actual details is the
baby was sleeping while breastfeeding so
he was very attached to me and I think
that yeah for your baby's sleeping and
again being an adult about the
conversation I think we all like sex
there's no secret about it how come
she's so slow she's vegan maybe she was
getting [ __ ] during that interview too
probably just be a multitask
she's like thinking about the baby at
the same time her videos oh it looked
like she was so distracted she was like
no I'm trying to think about what I want
to say there was this one part in the
video or in the interview too that
really disturbed a lot of people which
was when the hosts they were asking
they're trying to gauge like okay at
what point do you feel that it's
inappropriate for your kids to be in the
same room as you guys you're having sex
and so she was just saying like well I'm
pretty sure all of us have walked in on
our parents having sex once or twice
people never and then she was just like
they were like but is it okay and then
she was saying well I mean if you're
having sex and if you're enjoying it and
your children just happen I think I'm
it's fine and I'm like what what did you
just say so just they're saying that
like if you find it
okay then she thinks whatever is weird
because like I don't know why people are
giving her a platform to speak on like
that like I mean YouTube is kind of like
your own platforms that's whatever but
what's the whole point of bringing her
on she's not gonna say anything it's
enlightening I think it's just like the
media going look how [ __ ] weird this
person is that's pretty much I just said
like four words in a matter of a minute
she speaks so slow no well this whole
interview is about 6 7 minutes long 17
words medicine I could have sex while
holding one of my dogs that's me yeah
yeah there's times when we have been in
sex and then [ __ ] the dog walks in
where I go that's weird what are you
lucky to get it out oh the dog comes a
[ __ ] round we licks your butthole or
something you're like what look what you
did
cuz that dogs are serious they're just
like damn it
get out of here it snowed ruin the whole
mood laughs we just we just start
laughing like the heat sorry we kick out
our cats were like this is too weird you
guys really there's no way I could be
having sex and then I'm like oh yeah but
I'll picture at the same time that's
[ __ ] weird
oh I was just thoroughly disturbed by
listening to this woman and then I was
looking at her entire YouTube channel -
and all her videos are just talking
about like well we all have sexual
energy so let's be adults about it I'm
getting so sick and tired just cuz it's
natural can we just be talking about me
that's like that new word now dude
energy spiritual force shut the [ __ ] up
before there were all vibes yeah energy
it's just like the hot Warren I keep
hearing and now it's just everything I
say everybody's answer for everything
now so annoying so it's like yeah what
did you think about that person not not
about they don't talk about conversation
they don't talk about how the what the
person does and things like ah you know
what
just like the spiritual forces way me do
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] did you talk about
I'm not asking about that you [ __ ]
weirdo Jesus maybe we should go back to
the old school just call everything
cheap that [ __ ] has no Chi that
was a chi second as vampire I like it
yeah I never used any of that so keep
finding off Asian people that's true
energy and spiritual [ __ ] that's our
[ __ ] yeah it's rooted in [ __ ] mung
beans and roots there's like one Twitter
response to the show quote there's not a
law against sharing your life and this
person saying I'm sure there's one about
performing sex acts in front of your
kids oh gosh like this morning she likes
incest [ __ ] it I don't know bro yeah
that kid's gonna have some Oedipus
complex I guess I kind of understand
what she's saying
like when we were primitive creatures we
probably [ __ ] in front of kids all day
long yeah then she's just saying you
wouldn't be here you wouldn't be here I
wouldn't be yeah no [ __ ] you're not
answering the [ __ ] question [ __ ]
everybody loves says I also like
punching people to face but I'm not
allowed to do that all right now I'm in
also another one of her arguments is
well why can't kids watch movies and
violence and see people get killed
but not that they can't they're not so
she's basing her morals off of movies
and [ __ ] I get what she's saying she's
trying to be criminalize sex she's
normal normalize it because in this
country were more afraid of sex than we
are of violence that's what she's saying
- that's true but the way she's going by
it though it's kind of like dude we grew
from that primitive age where we're
[ __ ] in front of everywhere like dogs
we were closed now we just we do things
a lot of different society has changed
and you have to just go with the
cultural norms but I do agree with her
point of kind of we can't really make
sex into a criminal act or make it make
it this taboo topic we are adults now
but she went from here to here yeah she
did she did that yeah once you
kids involved that's a little bit
different and also once we take it out
of this country and in Europe they find
you who are very sexually liberal and
they still find you crazy I think
there's something wrong with what yeah
because if you talk about some natural
[ __ ] I want you to say that to like an
Aboriginal tribe and they're just like
man that's [ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
exactly titties out and everything off
but all like you [ __ ] front of your
kids have some decency yeah and if they
put on their [ __ ] nose ring and start
hunting a [ __ ] animal
yeah hey what's up guys thanks for
watching we are going to regularly start
posting content on the JK films
Instagram so make sure you follow us
there the last video click over here
[Music]